das jahr 2020 war in vielerlei hinsicht
anders als wir vermutet hatten viele
pläne die man hatte konnte man nicht
richtig umsetzen und so war es auch bei
mir denn ich wollte eigentlich nach
mexiko fliegen
das ging dieses jahr nicht
ich mir allerdings keinen strich durch
die gewagte die freunde denn die
reitfreunde trotzte ohnehin klar machen
wir sogar nicht mal deinen 08 15 bio
städtetrips
wir machen direkte weltreisen und
starten in amerika wo ich schon immer
mal hin und zwar wollte ich ja ganz gern
nach mexiko stadt aus eher einfallslos
ist die hauptstadt von mexiko einfach
mexiko stadt heißt ich hatte mir nämlich
ein hotel gebucht und zwar genau hier
[Musik]
da wollte ich schlafen hier wollte ich
kacke und hier ist das meine mutter von
mexiko stadt eine wundervolle stadt ich
würde sagen wir geben uns einfach mal
nach hinten hier sehen wir direkt dass
das ist die kathedrale von mexiko bauer
ja hier wollte ich auch schon mal hin
das ist der palacio de la bath
sandra kabinett gecheckt dass hier ist
der palacio de la palette wdh sprachen
lernen da sind wir gerne von außen dann
auch angucken
[Musik]
ja das ist angela merkel hier
tatsächlich gerade auf städtereise auch
xi kurs langweilig mexiko meine lieben
freunde ich wollte eigentlich auch nur
in die karibik sind mexiko war
hier wollte ich nämlich hin auf die
bahamas richtig da hatte ich ihn raus
angemietet hier war das das war das hier
genau das ist der vermieter gewesen das
war die pille und hier hätten wie
gewohnt und das tolle ist sie haben den
stand genau jetzt hier gar nicht bewegen
oder oder wie zwei tage später wirklich
so und jetzt sind wir hier beim strand
angekommen eine liebt
so
erst mal ein radler drei tage später
ja so
jetzt meine rundreise nicht vorgestellt
aber wir lassen uns davon überhaupt
nicht beirren denn das nächste ziel von
mexiko über die bahamas ist natürlich
richtig quadrath ichendorf das fahrrad
im dorf eine metropole in der nähe von
calais absolute wahnsinn vor allem
gefällt mir das hier vorne immer sehr
gut das ist nämlich der netto und stefan
raab und a22 autos mit spaß beiseite ich
meine lieben freunde wir reisen
natürlich trotz corona nach amerika in
den hotspot new york city und zwar
direkt hier zum empire state und tobago
meine lieben freunde da unten sehen wir
den times square denke ich mal oder es
ist einfach nur ein bildschirm
ja das ist new york hier
da ist eine brezel fallen lässt oder was
also das ist auf jeden fall new york wir
sehen hier vorne bord dieses dieses
gebäude ist so komisch was anstrich der
hochgeht die haben alle paar stockwerke
einfach luft gelassen dass er der wind
durch kann dass das ding nicht wackelt
und umfeld ja wir sind ja aber nicht für
sondern da wollten wir eigentlich zu
astro castro gallery of fine jewelry und
da gehen wir jetzt einkaufen hier trotz
corona allerdings müsse man dann erstmal
eine maske aufsetzen ein paar sekunden
später
ich habe meine eigenen mund
eingescannt und auf eine maske gedruckt
[Musik]
also wir sind jetzt hier in dem so
edelsteine ich früher gesammelt
ich erst mal waschen sollen wir mal ein
bild weiter die haben mein traum war
dass sie auch kein arbeiten wir zu teuer
wir gehen mal raus aber moskau wieder
abnehmen ja das war der erste jim james
lang noch augen zu und wir versuchen
jetzt den ort in new york
[Musik]
schön
mit einer
ach guck mal ist so langweilig meine
lieben freunde denn wir wollen natürlich
unsere welt reise fortsetzen und wo kann
man das besser tun als in der wüste ich
habe einfach sahara eingegeben und jetzt
sind wir hier mitten in afrika die sache
ist allerdings dass wir uns hier nicht
so trocken können
doch hier so da befinden uns jetzt mal
mit
euro
das ist mit der wohl mitten in der wüste
für dich was wir noch alles entdecken
kann tannenbaum
kerner wieder aufräumen hier dann gehen
wir als nächstes mal hier nach mauritz
maroni
da sind einer wüste angekommen meiner
lieben von openoffice oder wat wir sind
hier in der wüste
das ist dann dass das war es dann auch
was darf allerdings bei einer weltreise
schlechthin nicht viel
genau cuxhaven beide lieben freunde eine
wunderschöne stadt ich war hier
tatsächlich war als kleines kind das war
meine erste klassenfahrt habe ich
geweint weil ein kumpel so ein wasser so
ein regenwurm hat er gegessen bei so
einer wattwanderung
das jetzt zum norddeutsch
an der nahtstelle gerade in cuxhaven
wundervoller ort wir können uns einfach
wir können wir kannten ihn zu bewegen
kann ich ja doch hier hin da können wir
hingehen dass es auch klappt
den ganzen schwachsinn spaß beiseite
meine liebe freunde wir machen eine
weltreise und wollen uns wirklich nur
auf die ziele konzentrieren zu den wir
wirklich auch gerne reisen wollen würden
fukushima zb mega entspannter ort sehr
natürlich ich wohne dort hier
da
obendrauf hat man einen wunderschönen
blick ja das ist meine schule hier bei
mir ist auch wichtig während der
weltreise sich dann weiter zu bilden
da kommt auch reingehen das ist die frau
meier
ja das ist das schönste was ich hier
gesehen habe wir machen jetzt eine reise
zu einem ort den ich selber nicht kenne
meine lieben freunde ihr seht es jetzt
los
ich deutlich
denn
unsere seite
jetzt endet die gewinnzone
green lake und den finde ich persönlich
ziemlich und wieder zurück nach hamburg
meine lieben freunde denn ich wohne
genau hier
da
nicht in hamburg
was ich mir bei dem heutigen video
gedacht habe
[Musik]